-Thanks for coming on the show.
-Thank you for having me.
I love being here.
-Oh, please. I want to
congratulate you
on so many things.
I just want to start
with "West Side Story" --
uh, you --
-Thank you.
-Not too shabby.
You filmed that three years ago?
-Yeah, I was 16.
-In New York?
-Yeah, it was crazy.
It's kind of
a full circle moment
to have it come out now
in New York.
It's so cool.
I'm so happy to be a part of it.
-Do you remember
the audition for that?
-Yeah, I remember auditioning
in L.A. and I was thinking like,
"Oh, I'll just go do it,
just because it's
a cool experience --
any dancer's dream to audition
for "West Side Story."
And then I got there,
did the audition.
Went good, but I was like,
"That was fun. That was cool."
Didn't hear anything
for a little bit
and then flew back to New York,
got a callback,
and then walk in and
Steven Spielberg's in the room.
I was like, "Oh, cool. So this
is, like, the final audition."
-Yeah.
-Like, "I made it this far."
-You're like, are you the real
Steven Spielberg?
-Yeah.
-This is cool.
-I was like, "Cool, OK,
this is fun."
Also, I was, like,
one of the youngest ones,
so I was just kind of, like,
trying to soak it all in.
And then some time passed again,
and my agent called me
on, like, around Thanksgiving,
or maybe it was
Thanksgiving Day, and was, like,
"Yeah, so, like, we actually
heard back
from 'West Side Story,'" like,
"I'm really sorry,
you got the part."
And I was, like... [ screams ]
-Oh, yeah.
Hey, oh, heart attack.
-I literally had a heart attack.
-Yeah.
-I was like, "Cool, thank you,
but also, I'm kind of, like,
traumatized."
-Don't ever do that again, yeah.
-And then I was, like, "Oh,
I'm going to prank my mom now
and do the same exact thing."
Because I like, "This is
actually kind of funny."
-[ Laughs ]
-So then --
-So then I did it exactly
to my mom.
-Yeah, just told your mom
you had bad news.
-And she was, like, tears.
So yeah, it was fun.
-Well, here's a picture of you
and Steven on set.
I will say, the choreography
on this movie,
it's the most insane thing...
-Justin Peck is a genius.
-I've ever seen in my life.
I go, I -- It almost looks like
it's the same person 400 times.
-Everyone is so synchronized,
but has their own, like,
special --
-Different colors
and their own special thing.
And it's like it's --
it's amazing.
-Totally.
-You go, "What, that's not CGI?"
-Oh, definitely not.
Every dancer was, like,
so hardworking and so incredible
and so talented.
So it was just cool to be
a part of it.
Do the --
I know the actors, too.
I mean, do you get nervous
when you're having to act
in front of Steven Spielberg
and dance?
-Oh, my God, are you kidding?
I --
I was having a heart attack
the whole time.
-Yeah, you're, like,
"Can you please leave?"
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Do you mind just, like,
taking five over there?
-Please leave, Steven, thanks.
We'll take it from here.
I know it's your movie,
but yeah, I don't want to do it
in front of you.
-Thanks for letting us be here,
though.
-I appreciate it.
-Yeah.
-Uh, love "Jaws." Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Literally.
-Yeah, right?
-No, it was --
he actually made it
such an amazing environment.
He was just as excited
as we all were,
like, literally watching
the monitor,
jumping up and down,
so excited.
Like, it was his baby,
and I'm just so happy that he,
like, absolutely loved every bit
of the experience as well.
-That's pretty cool.
Did he want you to sing
in the movie?
-Um, I don't sing.
That's like a very known thing,
I think.
-Why?
-I -- You know...
I've learned --
I've come to the conclusion
that it's OK to not
be good at everything.
[ Laughter ]
And I've -- I've settled on,
"I'm not tone deaf,
and that's all that matters."
-OK. All right.
Well, yeah, but --
your boyfriend, though,
Eddie Benjamin needs --
-He's here.
-He's here tonight.
Yeah, he's backstage. But
he's -- he's a great singer.
I mean, but --
-He's amazing.
I will not sing in front of him.
Don't even ask me.
I never will.
-He's like Spielberg?
You're going to go
"Get out of the room?"
-Yeah, literally.
-I want to sing this song.
-But no, he doesn't. He doesn't
go, "Hey, just come on.
Let's just do this one song
together or something."
-Uh, you know, he's like,
"I could teach you.
I could -- like, I know you're
going to have to
do a role one day where you're
going to have to sing."
I'm, like, "No, I'll probably
have to turn it down
because that's how bad it is."
-No, there's no way.
-No, but he's there in case,
you know, one day maybe --
-Training.
-Yeah.
-He's going on tour
with Justin Bieber.
-Yes, he is.
-Now, this is a big deal.
-A huge deal.
-Yeah.
-I mean, obviously, I was, like,
the biggest Justin Bieber fan
when I was younger.
I mean, everyone was, like --
-Hello, I'm the biggest -- yeah.
-Yeah, of course.
-I was a Belieber since day 1.
-I was a Belieber, yeah.
-Totally.
-Yeah.
Yeah, so it's, like,
a very full-circle moment.
I actually met him
when I was, like, 8 years old
with my dance group,
which is so weird.
We were like beside ourselves.
It was the coolest.
-What was he like?
-I -- I actually don't even
remember. I was star-struck.
-Really?
-Yeah, totally.
-Like... [stammers]
-I don't even -- I think it
happened so quickly.
We were just all crying,
and then that was it.
So, yeah.
He was really cute, though.
-Oh, yeah, he's a good guy.
Are you going to go on tour?
-Oh, definitely. I definitely
would love to see Justin,
of course, but I cannot wait to
watch Eddie perform.
-That's what I'm talking about.
-I'm so excited.
-I'm going to be, like,
the groupie,
just, like, following along
everywhere.
-I love you!
-Yeah.
-No, I really do.
We love each other.
-Yes. [ Laughs ]
-Hiya.
I'm like, "That's my boyfriend!"
-That's my boyfriend!
-Yeah.
I want to talk
about "The Fallout."
-Yes.
-Congratulations on this.
-Thank you.
-Rave reviews.
It won the Grand Jury Prize.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Won the Grand Jury Prize for
best film at SXSW.
-So crazy.
-It's massive.
-It's -- [stammers]
-It's a beautiful movie.
Can you explain
what "The Fallout" is about?
-Yeah. "The Fallout" is
a coming-of-age story
about high schoolers
who share a unique bond,
and they're kind of navigating
love and self-discovery
and healing, kind of
in the aftermath of a tragedy
that happens at the school.
-Yeah.
-So yeah, it's --
it's a heavy one, for sure.
-And is it true that I heard
that you improvised some scenes?
-Yeah, a lot of the time,
Megan -- the director and
writer, she's incredible,
and she was an actor previously,
so she definitely, like,
just let us do our thing,
which was amazing.
And at the end of each scene,
she'd be, like,
"Let's just do a fun run.
You guys do whatever you want."
And a lot of those scenes ended
up making the movie
just because...
-It makes it so real.
And it's really --
it's great.
-Thank you.
-Great performance. Congrats.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Maddie Ziegler
in "The Fallout."
Take a look at this.
[ Laughter ]
-You're, like, yodeling.
-You probably don't know this
about me,
but I'm the best yodeler
in my family.
-Prove it.
-But --
You can't put me on the spot
like that,
'cause then that's just, like,
you know --
-This is, like,
the little preview.
-Yeah, this is, like, warm up.
-OK.
-You know, but I'm going to get
you when you're not even ready,
and you're going to be, like...
[gasps dramatically]
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, you know, this might sound
weird because, like,
I haven't known you
for that long,
but, like, I feel
so comfortable with you.
Like, we're bonded or something.
-Same.
-Maddie Ziegler, everybody.
"The Fallout" premiers
January 27th on HBO Max.